on a un président de la république qui
refuse de débattre il est pas là ce soir
c'est normal il va dans des salles il va
devant des salles avec des gens triés là
on a pu remarquer que j'avais pas trier
la salle
et il y va et il y va avec des questions
posées à l'avance pour être sûr de
pouvoir répondre je suis désolé chiffre
8 sans papiers donc je ne sais pas
quelles questions vous allez me poser et
je suis prête à tout y répondre non mais
c'est quand même dingue franchement
d'habitude quand il ya une élection
quand il ya un sortant il vient et il
dit écoutez voilà mon bilan alors c'est
vrai que la droite a pas tout bien fait
c'est vrai que peut-être on aurait dû
faire plus mais en 2012 quand nicolas
sarkozy et il est allé à l'élection il y
est allé avec son bilan et il a dit
voilà ce que j'ai fait et voilà ce que
je vais faire pour la france là on a
même plus de débat on n'a rien alors moi
je vous le dis quand même ne vous
laissez pas voler cette élection est
franchement demander des débats demandez
des débats demandé le bilan demandé
aussi le projet parce que le projet
trois heures de conférence de presse et
on l'attend toujours pense qu'il faut il
faut vraiment qu'on réussisse nous les
républicains a montré que clairement on
est en programme avec avec un programme
totalement de rupture avec emmanuel
macron parce que c'est ça la réalité
mais c'est ça la réalité il ya les
différences les différences sont
colossales les différences sont
colossales d'abord il ya une différence
de vision de vision de la france moi ma
france notre france elle est une et
indivisible c'est pas une addition de
communauté
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya pas des
cultures en france y'a qu'une sud qu'une
seule culture française nous jamais on
accuserait la france d'avoir commis un
crime contre l'humanité en algérie c'est
pas notre vision de la france donc sur
tous ces sujets là et puis nous on veut
pas de construire l'histoire de france
nous on est là droite voilà donc ça
c'est la première chose on n'a pas la
même vision de la france qu emmanuel
macron la deuxième chose c'est qu'on n'a
pas la même vision des français
moi dans ma vision de la france qui est
une vision gaulliste social il n'y a pas
des français qui ne sont rien et jamais
jamais au grand jamais vous m'entendrez
dire à un seul de mes compatriotes qu'il
n'a pas de dignité donc ça c'est une
différence et puis par ailleurs jamais
nous nous ne dirions que nous voulons
emmerder certaines catégories de
français nous on est plutôt comme
pompidou nous on voudrait plutôt qu'on
arrête de les emmerder
et que ondées bureaucratise et qu'on
simplifie